Candace is in Texas hey Candace welcome
to the Dave Ramsey show how can we help
you today
hi and so we are in the December 4th or
only that is our mortgage and today we
found out that my husband's contract
position with his company is ending on
Friday and our mortgage company is
offering a forbearance option for koba's
related income issues and I was just
wondering if I get your advice on
whether we should take the forbearance
or use our emergency fund way that we
just finished savings to pay for our
mortgage and expenses so what does he do
and he works at an advertising or in a
healthcare industry in the advertising
space time so if his own contract his
job is come and go anyway in it well
it's the contact was actually over and
they just kept him going for months and
months now because they really like him
but it's the company that he is
contacted through they just have kept
him so what was his plan career-wise if
the contract had ended other than in the
middle of ours they put a freeze on
hiring that company wanted to hire him
but that so his plan was for that
company to hire him yes and I think
there their plan was eventually to hire
again but because all the stuff they
were on our freeze beforehand and so
once they were off the freeze they were
gonna enter um I want to say around 70
we're both full-time employed also so am
I also in addition to no no no Mike I
have a full-time Oh as well so what do
you much I make 105
why can't you put your health plan I
think we probably could make our house
on many changes especially with our like
a hundred five thousand dollars a year
mm-hmm
we just we just bought this house so I'm
just nervous
yeah I think and you're freaking out but
you're not doing math okay let's do math
okay one hundred and five thousand
dollars a year how much your house
payment it's thirty seven thirty seven
hundred dollars a month seven hundred
yes thank you couch okay
all right so you know eight thousand
seven thousand dollar take-home pay so
it's 50 percent of your take-home pay
dad big old house all right and he used
to make seventy so what's he gonna do is
he gonna go get a job or go sometimes
but I think you look he's already
started talking to some people that we
know and sending out I've been talking a
lot about the forbearance stuff lately
I'm gonna tell you I Candice I would I
would stay away from the forbearance the
only thing that's gonna happen with that
is is that a they're gonna either delay
or extend your period of indebtedness as
they've said do the math make the
payment on this this is not something
you need to play around with but I would
tell you this the most important thing
your husband needs from you right now is
encouragement for him to reach out to
co-workers colleagues and as soon as he
can get money coming in the better off
he is gonna be psychologically and you
guys will be financially so that's the
route I'm gonna go so you guys stay
plugged in but you're gonna have to
delete the unnecessary things out of
your budget as Dave and I've been
calling it this is conserve mode right
now and so you guys need to get really
really intentional don't keep life going
as you know it you've taken a seventy
thousand dollar pay cut right now and
until that gets fixed life needs to
change yeah but if it takes a month to
fix it he's fine
you know you've got plenty of money
you're in good shape you can do this for
a month this is you don't want to have a
house payments 50% take-home pay for
five years but for four months or
something you're gonna be okay and
you've got an emergency from the
backfill see forbearance doesn't mean
forgiveness it just means kick the can
down the road it means that you know you
know if you don't pay the payment this
month you got to pay it next month if
you don't pay next month you got to pay
two payments the next month
and if you don't pay it the next month
by September you've got four payments
that you're gonna owe and so it's not
really a blessing hmm it's it's a form
of denial and I would rather you go
ahead and deal with it tighten up your
budget pay the payment if you have to
dip into your mergency fund a little bit
but I don't even think you have to dip
into it I think you can exist if you
stop everything else right now except
that and then have him get on ken
Coleman's website and learn everything
you can about getting his job replaced
really really fast and I hold on we'll
send you a copy of Ken's book the
proximity principle and get you going
Dave you you've been a real estate guy
and you're a whole lot older than me a
whole lot older oh but the work the term
forbearance back in your day I was
always taught that that meant that
whatever was behind had to be made up
before moving forward yeah okay
forbearance what you and I have done in
coaching and counseling and what you're
referring to is if somebody comes into
the office and they're three house
payments behind we'll jump on the phone
as a coach right with the mortgage
company and work out a forbearance and
they send you a forbearance agreement
and if there's three payments behind it
might be that you pay double payments
for three months right all right might
pay you pay a payment and a half for six
months but there's a get current process
right absolutely but all forbearance the
word literally just means patience it
does not mean forgiveness I didn't know
that it means we're gonna work it out
over the next little while but if you
just don't pay it at all
you're just piling it up and you're
gonna look up in September and owe for
payments and thirty seven hundred bucks
a pop that's called sixteen thousand
dollars that's a lot of money with late
charges everything else that's right no
thank you